ok in corso
[Musica]
benvenuti solita stai per chi siamo al
buio
siamo nel castello siamo ancora qui al
buio abbiamo deciso di fare una
challenge e cioè esplorare il castello
al nuovo noiosi ronde se vi state
chiedendo che i capelli strani che hai
anita perché non li ho piastrati questi
in realtà sono i miei capelli e naturale
gol bellissimi ondulati mulas avvocato
per piastra rica per esse non abbiamo
ancora trovato la finestra lettera
quindi non abbiamo nessuna nuova lettera
del re meglio che cerchiamo in giro e
magari riusciremo a trovarlo voi la foto
mi piace per portarci fortuna e dovremo
parlare a voce bassa perché notte anche
voi se volete immergervi a stimo a noi
nella challenge vedete se notate
qualcosa di strano e ora pronti vicina e
così siamo qua fuori questo è il nostro
balconcino
il problema è che anche sei tardissimo
non è ancora buio completamente sta
facendo buio sempre più tardi noi
inizieremo a fare un giro comunque
assieme a voi e aspetteremo che arrivi
la notte
la mattina stimo il castello questo è un
tramonto quella successo
senti tutti questi rumori sono le cicale
là sopra sull'albero e si stanno
cantando
sì è vero le citate cambio in questa la
loro canzone ufficiale l'as fiscale che
i cani non so che cantone chissà se le
scale si sposa bene questo è mio l'ho
preferito anche se io a molti figli
bellissimo sai come si chiama sos albero
come si chiama e un letto e non è un
abitante di lecce da quanti anni è
davvero magico a quest'ora il castello
dovrebbe essere per usa se non sbaglio
provo per uso scendiamo giù nel giardino
del castello e se troviamo qualcosa
questo è il tunnel di piante del
castello e bene il tunnel in campo tanto
guardate che bella questa pianta tipo
crosta è stupenda bellissimo il colore
vabbè per tutto il video anita vitale
che parlano e si innamorano delle piante
degli alberi e per non parlare dei
cipressi quanto sono ben guardate sono
quelli sono quegli alberi lunghi lunghi
ea punta non sono quelli sono altissimi
ora siamo nel roseto le rose sono uno
dei miei fiori preferiti gli altri miei
fiori preferiti sono le begonie belle
sono bianche bianchissime e hanno messo
tutta qua dentro con bianchi chiami post
marino e le poteri forti
poi ci sono delle rose rosa qualche
grande a voi piacciono le piante i fiori
gli alberi scrivetecelo nei commenti qui
sono i vostri fiori preferiti
abbiamo sopra ok devo smetterla di
fissarmi con i fiori e gli alberi
andiamo di qua cerchiamo di indigenza è
quasi buio vedi o nonché acceso le luci
al castello queste teste sono più
inquietanti adesso cambiato espressione
che vogliate
è illuminato invece sta guardando la
sotto se ci saranno scorto qualcosa da
sotto ma no non c'è niente ora vi pare
cibo concreti come così sei riuscita a
vederci
ci siamo seduti qua in questa panchina
nel parco del castello e stiamo
aspettando di sentire o vedere qualcosa
magari arriverà proprio il re di persona
sì siamo qui nel giardino insieme alle
sue statue magari verrà proprio qui ad
incontrarci almeno sapremo costato biamo
fare se possiamo tornare a casa se siamo
liberi
insomma che cosa dovremmo fare che
cos'era
hai visto dove siamo dove siamo guardate
la sopra c'è il terrazzo aspetti magari
ci vuole dire qualcosa
vai tu vuoi parlarci io non ci vado io
mi allontano proprio di no l'unità non
mi lasciare tutto l'aspettavi ha paura
di questa sfida si è visto una lazio
la luna è quasi piena lo vedete abbiamo
pochissimo tempo per risolvere questo
mistero questo enigma questa maledizione
sbrighiamoci che magari andiamo dirà ok
ma non avviciniamoci al terrazzo ok
[Musica]
queste forse sono le segrete ci sono le
spadare
ho sentito un rumore quassù nello stand
sì andiamo a controllare entrato io non
c'entro ok ma lo si vede vieni per cento
la luce qui non c'è nessuno aspetta
manuale l'ho già nessuno sei tu che hai
detto che è sentito un rumore quasi lo
sciopero o poi avete sentito qualcosa
[Musica]
non vogliamo farti del male che che cosa
sei anche tu se vuoi fare del male noi
vai pure via da questa stanza segue poi
esplorare le altre stanze del castello
quello sono neanche il giardino con le
rose pro basta che vai via grazie ciao
l'atrofia davvero comparso questo vi sia
la dietro il troll armadio non penso che
sia andato via non controllare e oggi mi
ha passato questa nuova esperienza
me ne vado io controllare se ci vai con
questa volta io c'ho troppo paura che
dovevamo la porta cosa succede qualcosa
quindi subito controllare che si si io
sto qui sentato in bagno poi prendere un
cuscino modelli di modelli verranno
cucinate meglio non farla arrabbiare ma
effettivamente regione anita stai
attenta accendi la luce vita che è
successo insomma gli scherzi mai pago
c'è nessuno aveva una vita
anita perché non ti sento più
non mi stai facendo un altro scherzo
vero dai non mi fare un altro scherzo
però anita
amico è successo guarda visto forse uno
degli abitanti di cui ci ha parlato il
re entrato lì ma ci sia qualcosa guarda
abbassato la prossima lettera non ho
capito una cosa ma qua dietro c'è per
caso una porta una porta che è sparita
per questo che c'è questo simbolo qua
c'è una porta segreta
dobbiamo trovare il maggiore giusto
vabbè ci pensiamo dopo
ora leggiamo l'ha letta si chiede che
cosa c'è scritto nella lettera sia
proprio una lettera ufficiale del re al
suo stemma kiss perché l'ha lasciata il
fantasma forse un suo messaggero apriamo
la cosa dici questi complimenti siete
ancora vive
però non mi abbia toccato nessuno
abitante del castello altrimenti avrete
una maledizione che vi terrà
intrappolati qui per sempre
per fortuna siamo stati a distanza
altrimenti salvo rimasti prigionieri qui
meno male sono rimasto all'ingresso non
mi sono avvicinato troppo la prossima
lettera si trova nel punto più alto del
castello buona fortuna e attenti a non
cadere in rete inter non cadere allora
deve essere proprio in alto la prossima
lettera forse intende sul tetto dobbiamo
salire sul tetto sul tetto del castello
sembra troppo ovvio che sia quello il
punto più alto del castello secondo me è
più difficile
secondo fuori la torre del castello che
non ci resta che andare a salire sopra
il castello a cercare di andare il più
in alto possibile e provare a non cadere
sperando che non ci siano altri abitanti
in presenze strane là sopra neanche
presente ci potrebbero essere là sopra
arcieri forse un drago
non penso non esistono i draghi sei
sicura non esistono
non esistono neanche i fantasmi eppure
mi sembrava un fantasma
magari è lui che ci vuole fare qualche
scherzo sto cercando di spaventarci e
non dobbiamo farsi demoralizzare voi
lasciate un mi piace trasportarci
fortuna
[Musica]